I think I got really unlucky in the
first six months I know there was other
people that weren't working as hard as
me that were doing deals quicker than me
and that was frustrating but ultimately
I was driven because I'd moved to London
taken this job and a massive rent that I
just simply couldn't afford so it was
like I had to make this work welcome
back to another episode of the
recruitment mentors podcast I'm your
host hea Maus and on this week's episode
I was joined by Rob leg Rob is the
classic recruitment story of someone who
started out worked extremely hard after
some adversity not billing in his first
four to 6 months since that moment he
has been the back-to-back top performer
at develop wck eight years with develop
w 8 years in recruitment yeah I feel
like your journey sort of epitomizes
what's possible in recruitment you know
when you work hard when you have those
interviews and say look we've got this
person that's done this they've started
where you are they you know climbed the
rank
his best performing year today is
989 Grand he's always done some perm
some contract and in this conversation
we really break down how Rob has
continued to build on his performance
year after year what is he doubled down
on why he's always open to learning but
there's people out there that think that
they know best and think that they like
why would I learn from Rob or like why
am I going to learn from this person
they haven't been doing it as long as me
like how have you naate approach that
people it's really difficult it's person
to person isn't it and it it kind of
depends on enjoy this week's episode Rob
welcome to the podcast thanks for having
me thanks for uh making the trip
obviously you uh now live in Southampton
Portsmouth Portsmouth as a Southampton
fan I should never admit
that yeah yeah moved to Ports two years
ago yeah nice um looking forward to
breaking down this journey that you're
run AB eight years we've developed recck
eight years in recruitment yeah so we've
got a lot to unpack I think what I'm
really excited about this is I feel like
your journey sort of epitomizes what's
possible in recruitment you know when
you work hard when you have those
interviews and say look we've got this
person that's done this they've started
where you are they you know climbed the
ranks so we're going to talk a lot about
you know how you think you've continued
to get better at your Craft um so just
to give people the the career highlight
real yeah um you let me know if I'm uh
like missing anything important here so
firstly um performance- wise so first
year uh you did 8 87 Grand second year
98 Grand third year 148 yeah then 324
then
457 then 524 and then 984 that was your
best year yeah and then up until
recently you've always been like je desk
contract um and then I can't remember
what you said in terms of like typically
the split along that journey is it being
like 50/50 is it been 60 p contract
probably more 7030 towards perm and then
30% contract yeah yeah okay cool and
then I know for a long time you was very
much you know an individual contributor
but then 2018 you started to Mentor
people 2019 you then um you know became
a team lead at the highest point you was
managing 16 people which is crazy then
uh you know have I think now around a
team of eight people right yeah that's
correct cool and then just to break down
his best performing year then CU I think
people always interested in like the
sort of makeup of it y so again let me
know if any of this um is is wrong MH
but I think you said 40 perm placements
y 27 contract placements yeah uh across
five clients in contracts yeah um and
then on the perm side 19 you had 19 perm
clients and only six of them you did one
placement with there's a lot of repeat
stuff yeah um I think you put down you
worked really hard to have like three
you had a fre key P clients and then
average it was around 11 Grand yeah
majority of it was um contingent but
then there's other models as well that
you do around 70% yeah we do a lot of
product Focus yeah selling as well
that's the career highlight will mate
sorry to break that down in like a
minute because it's like there's so much
hard work that's gone into that
no look you know it's uh over eight
years putting it into that one minute it
sounds crazy doesn't it really yeah
that's a real like you know real like I
said like just that classic journey of
like just consistently getting better
staying in the game long enough to reap
the rewards of all that hardw work over
time and then I guess just to round that
out then so your Market has always been
net yeah net yeah so let's start with
the million pound question then like
what what do you believe are the the
common characteristics and traits of a
top performing recruiting in today's
market
um I think there's always like the
buzzword that get thrown around a lot so
like resilience is one um this job is
difficult there's no doubt about that I
think people have to be able to uh take
the knocks and dust themselves off and
learn from it but like what I look for
in people really is ability to learn um
emotional intelligence communication
skills um be able to positively
challenge people as well um but I just
like work ethic is massive right you've
got to you've got to put the Graft in
like I my first three years I just
worked so hard I didn't care about what
else was going on in the office and
never got distracted during my Sal
Sprints I wanted to learn from the best
people and sit with the best people just
acted as basically a sponge for that
that first year got a a really good
framework in place and then started to
add my own color to it so um there's
loads are stuff and I think it's all
kind of dependent on the person and your
selling style but um there's some real
key ones in there that are super
important for to look out for I think
eight years is a long time so let's just
I think I want to go into the the key
bits that you think is being fundamental
to helping you like complete uh continue
progressing your performance but have to
start with first six months you didn't
do a deal mhm
so like look looking back do you think
there's what was the fundamental things
that maybe you felt like you was doing
wrong looking cuz you you maybe pick up
on this now and you manage people like
looking back was it anything that you
think fundamentally you're like I just
didn't quite get this or I really
struggle with that I think cuz I didn't
really have any kind of sales background
um I came from a customer service
focused um background previously I used
to work for an e-commerce business doing
that um so that sort of transitioned
from making everyone happy to sort of
being able to positively challenge
people was something that I learned
pretty quickly I think I got really
unlucky in the first six months I know
there was other people that were doing
weren't working as hard as me that were
doing deals quicker than me and that was
frustrating but um ultimately I was
driven because I'd moved to London
taking this job and a massive rent that
I just simply couldn't afford so it was
like I had to make this work um but yeah
I I look back at it now and think
there's probably a big element of just
getting unlucky with with certain
situations I had offers out there I had
a placement drop out but I think
actually that helped me moving into my
career later on because I think I've
often seen people get success early in
Recruitment and then kind of think oh
this job's actually pretty easy um and
you get a kind of almost a bit of a
false economy for it so failing failing
early was was really good for me I think
in terms of my my development that been
a bit of a blessing yeah I think so yeah
cuz you are right I think you can
there's Pro I guess his pros and cons
right it's great to get like a a win
quite quickly yeah it's tough to yeah be
blanking every month seeing people
around you um doing uh yeah doing deals
but then as you said I think the real
challenge of and I spoke to so many
people where they did get success
quickly but almost they that sort of set
them up to fail cuz then when they had
those periods of like it was really
difficult they're still learning their
craft they then blanked for a couple of
months they really find that hard to
take cuz they've got the the previous
success stor to look at go hell
like what I was I was doing this
previously yeah and it's um when you're
still in your sort of infancy of your
recruitment career you that those knocks
are harder to take I think um you get a
bit more thicker skinned as you get get
on with it I think so let like just
curious to get your thoughts on this I
don't know how many people have sat down
that um I haven't sat down with loads of
people that have a dual desk Okay so
what's like fundamental to you know
being a world-class dual Des recruiter
cuz that I just feel like that must be
difficult yeah I mean it's it's not it's
definitely not easy um and I think the
way that we've always ran je desk is
that we'd either focus on one or the
other right um and then you kind of
almost stumble
upon um options so I always used to
basically predominantly Chase perm leads
and when I'd get into a position where
say for example someone had had a net
developer vacancy open for six months
they've got challenges across the role
for various different reasons that's a
great opportunity to sell back a
contractor because a lot of people at
that stage it's impacting projects so I
need to get someone in there so then you
get a good contractor in there and then
what ends up happening is they still
want to hire the perm but that contract
has been great so they just extend them
time and time again um we've also been
super fortunate that we've got some big
accounts that both myself and Joe and
Kev and the business have won and um
hire a lot of contracts in in that net
development space so I guess I was
fairly fortunate that there was probably
one or two when I joined that would hire
a lot of contractors and needed someone
to deliver into that and then just
naturally started to to work in that you
find it difficult to like switch from is
what what's like fundamentally the same
would you say um from the Perman
contract side I mean sourcing is the
same but the yeah you there's a bit of a
shift in um how you would run a
qualification for perm and contract I
mean contractors they don't typically
care too much about the culture or the
team or you know there's no benefits and
things like that they're they're really
just Keen to know what technology and
the projects are so um yeah when when
you're running those qualifications
everything moves at a much faster Pace
with contract like our average time to
hire on contract was 24 hours on permit
was 2.6 weeks so like we knew that if we
found a great candidate we had to get
get them place the next day cuz
otherwise we were going to miss out on
them so um and I think there's a massive
relationship building session to both
but in different ways like for
contractors you want to understand you
know what they're looking for in
projects and then what what their end
date is on their current project so that
you can get ahead of it get to people
before they become active on job boards
or or LinkedIn um obviously with permits
typically you're looking for people that
maybe they're more passive like already
in jobs so you need to understand
exactly what they're dream looks like so
yeah it's it's fundamentally the same
but there's um there's nuances with it I
think I've heard a lot of I was on the
call yesterday was on boarding a new
recruitment company they were saying
about like they have this like uh top
performer but they're really trying to
encourage them to you know expand their
accounts yeah you know te up of
opportunities for the team and
particularly that was around like the
contract element cuz I have a contract
team yeah so like I think a lot of
people uh if they have that environment
they might have a contract in the perm
team you know there's a real opportunity
to cross sell OB ultimately doing that
for yourself yeah so like what have you
found to be like the key when it comes
to cuz I'm sure you might have even have
you know your manager say right Rob like
I really want you to be pushing if they
you know you speak to them about like
you're chasing perm leads and then it
doesn't um they you then figure out
actually these are their paying points
I'm going to talk about contractors I
think sometimes I don't know from what
I've taken people can struggle with that
so what would you say is like really key
if you want to get really good at okay I
might lead with perm but then if I see
these certain things or I hear these
certain things yeah yeah I then switch
to okay well how about this solution
well I I think it comes down to knowing
how you're going to solve that client's
problem um so if someone comes to me and
says look I need to get someone on this
project by next week feasibly I'm not
going to be able to get them unless I
get really lucky with someone that's
come out on redundancy or just caught
them at a good time realistically a
contract is going to be the best
solution to that problem um so I think
it's like that qualification piece is so
important to find out right okay what
what does this what does this person
need to solve their problem and then I'm
going to use my expertise to say this is
your best way of of of solving it so if
I need to get someone on that project
tomorrow it's going to be contract if
it's like right well I need someone
longer term because I need someone
bought into the product and um into the
vision of the company is it is contract
going to be the best option for them
there probably not but can they can they
wait for a burn person so it's hearing
those sorts of keys yeah yeah during
that qualification process so important
so one thing that I wanted to start with
CU When We prepped for this something
that really stuck out to me was you said
organization and prep is the key to
recruitment y I'm a firm believer of
that to to to move through that um so
the way that we're set up at developers
we we run sprints so we're super strict
with the the time and the activities
that we do during that time and I've
seen you know I've only ever had
experience of working with developers I
only really know one way um and I feel
our way works well um I've seen people
that have come from other business
businesses where it's just like you know
what do what you got to do and and make
it happen I think without structure and
organization that's really really
difficult because you're spinning so
many plates there's so many things that
you need to do and it's so easy to get
distracted so unless it's money critical
my guys won't do anything outside of
their Sprint hours other than the
activity that we're we're set out to do
and I think that creates a really nice
collaboration piece between the team
that we're all doing the same activity
at the same time kind of get that sort
of real comaraderie of like when people
are in it in a business development
Sprint they get a knockback or you know
you can kind of put a bit of an arm
around people or if they have a good
call you can celebrate some more wins
and forward actions and things like that
so um yeah organization and prep is
something that I drill into a team I'm
very like methodology and process driven
and I think that's been one of the keys
for for how successful I've been is the
amount of time that I invest outside of
my core selling time to go and make sure
that I've got a brilliant candidate list
of people that I want to speak to I've
got calls booked in my business
development Sprint I've you know I'm
following up on on my leads that I've
respect or invites to events and
podcasts or whatever whatever it may be
I've always got stuff to follow up so
it's not doesn't feel like cold cooling
it feels like right I'm actually I've
got a reason to speak to these people so
let's break this down and how do we run
a successful spring cuz I'm sure like
that's been a journey for you sometimes
I'm sure some weeks you think the
Sprints were Mega this week there'll be
some weeks they this week so what
how do we for managers listening yeah
like firstly just interested we're go
into like how you think you yeah set
that up to like have the the best chance
of it going really well but like if we
were to look at the week then how many
Sprint like how many Sprints are there
in a week how do you break that down so
we do four Sprints a day four Sprints a
day yeah so two phone Sprints two
digital Sprints um and then obviously we
have time about an hour's time for doing
admin so how long are the digital how
long are the Sprint two hours we found
so I used to play around with the times
a little bit so we tried three hour
Sprints but I think people start to lose
a bit of um um you know you get
distracted and lose a bit of focus after
that sort of time I did one and a half
hour Sprints but I felt like we were
always extending it by an extra half an
hour to get the extra calls that we
needed because so if you do four Sprints
then so what does that look like in the
day the time slots yeah so we basically
we start at half eight we do a standup
we talk about what our non-negotiables
are and and what we're planning to do
for the day 9:00 to 11:00 is our first
business development Sprint yeah um 11
to1 is then our follow-up Sprint to that
because typically when you've done a
phone Sprint you've got lots of actions
off the back of it that you need to
follow up on and then yeah then we have
lunch um kind of do a bit of prep work
we do a little stand up again and sort
of like get together before our candate
Sprint talk about what we're looking to
achieve so 2 till four uh is our
candidate Sprint and then four till 6
we'll do our digital Sprint and that
will include any kind of admin booking
interviews interview feedback that kind
of stuff so yeah keeps it pretty simple
then do it so like let how do we how do
manag run a successful Sprints I think
the the key to it is making sure
everyone's set up and on board so we do
it's still a work in progress for us I'm
not saying that we've nailed it at all
but um I think we've got loads better
with it where we're publicly holding
people accountable to what they say
they're going to achieve um I do a lot
of stuff where um show and tell me
basically with like let's look at your
call list let's look at your prep work
if it's not where it need needs to be
then I know that I can run a surgery
session or a coaching session to say
well we could we could do this or you
know if we're having problems with your
Boolean or that you know your digital
touch Point's not good enough you're not
getting responses from stuff or you
don't have a a decent list then we need
to to look at that so that we can
Rectify it um and then it's like right
okay well you know we
um I think we use slack um and we're
pretty um focal on that across the team
and sort of encourage the team to add
their add their wins as we go so that it
kind of if someone's having a bit of a
bad Sprint you can say look it's only
going to take you one more call to get
that perfect candidate or um you know
get get a client on the phone and a
decent forward action so so where the
people normally fall short is it the
prep for the Sprints prep is the the big
thing I think people fall short on um I
think it's sometimes difficult to manage
Sprints from home like we we run a a
hybrid working po policy so when people
are at home you have to be you have to
be super selfmotivated to do it by
yourself um you know it's easy to get
distracted by other things going on at
home and things like that so yeah that
that can be challenging but I think the
beauty of what we do obviously we've got
all these analytics platforms that um
give us an overview and it's really easy
for me to be able to see how well my
team's morning's been based on what's
going into what's going into Ball Horn
what's going into Cube what what wins
we're celebrating and all that kind of
stuff so you know we try to avoid
being like we don't want to be like big
brother but I think at early stages if
you if that's the way that you're
working then yeah yeah like you've
agreed that like this we've all agreed
that this is the best way for us to be
as productive as possible yeah if they
haven't done the Sprint then you have to
hold them accountable yeah of course
yeah and look all the guys we we did our
kickoff last year and I spoke to my team
and said look you know what what do you
want me to do more of and they were like
I want you to get back to I I'd stop
sharing phone time and dials and all
that kind of stuff beforehand and they
were like I want you to get back to that
until we get back to where we want to be
from a performance point of view so all
of them asked me to do that you know
whether they like that every day or not
is a is a is a different story but I
think you know sometimes to be a good
manager you have to tell people what
they need to hear not what they want to
hear mhm and then just I know you're
getting gring here what does good prep
look like for a BD Sprint like what what
should I have with me ready what like
what does a good prep yeah what is good
like for a BD Sprint so from my point of
view you've run a really solid digital
touch uh BD digital touch Point process
beforehand so either you've got a list
of 40 leads that you know higher in your
space so the way that that we work at
developer we're inch wide mile deep so
pure Market specialist um so we should
know everyone that hires in our space
naturally because that's all we do on a
day and day out basis um so yeah what I
want to see from people is that we've
got at least a list of 40 with numbers
that we've had some sort of digital
touch point with whether that's
connection on LinkedIn an invite to our
we do a lot of events at Wembley and um
you know whether it's podcast sessions
or it's um added value with salary
benchmarking something for us to go and
follow up and then right we're going to
we're going to attack that list during
that that Sprint okay so yeah it's got
to be that if you're going into a
business development Sprint not knowing
who you're going to call not having
numbers against anyone to speak to or
anything to follow
up you're not you're not going to have a
great Sprint and then like just curious
then on these BD Sprints like what's the
context of the phone call like I know it
will vary but like typically like if
I've got all that that you just
described am my so you said there that
they they their companies that are
hiring did you say typically yeah
typically I think
also you know we we want to be engaging
with people that work in our space like
even if there's a net engineering
manager that isn't necessarily hiring
right now I still want to speak to them
I still want to understand what their
plans are looking like for projects and
hiring and what their biggest challenges
have been so and then you know it's it's
a massive relationship game what we do
so like being able to call people and
not just like we don't want to just call
them and and talk to them about
candidates all the time we want that's
what I mean yeah is that what's is that
typically what's happening is that like
CU it's it's a mixture it depends on the
the quality of your lead right if you
know that someone's hiring you've got
information that that person is looking
and they're they're struggling yeah I
might want to speak to him about
candidate but most of the time it's like
how can I how can I add value to your
process what's you know what are you not
getting from your current suppliers or
recruitment recruitment cycle at the
moment or other methods you know so like
it's a bit of a fact find really for
that first call but if I've already
spoken to him and I've already kind of
found that stuff out I'm starting to
open up uh conversations about projects
and timelines and you know all that good
stuff as well as the opportunity to try
and get these people face to face and
then what about I feel like then what
about the like okay so the prep's
absolutely fundamental if you don't do
the prep you're going to struggle to you
know be productive in any Sprint or do
whatever uh you do but then what about
like making time to reflect on how that
Sprints been yeah I think we do we I run
surgery sessions with the guy so I
basically I I um dedicate at least an
hour in the morning an hour in the
afternoon for people to bring calls to
me or certain situations to me to say do
you know what I'd I'd like to listen to
this because I don't think this was a
great call and I'd like to analyze it
and let's talk about it um I think
that's really important for improvement
because um you don't know what you don't
know at early stages of your career
right and you know if people don't tell
you you're doing something doing
something wrong or you could change some
sort of terminology or the way that you
ask things um you're just going to
continue doing it and then and then kind
of expecting different results so yeah
that's super important for people to do
a lot of self-reflection and I think you
know one of our values is commitment to
constant learning so we invest a huge
amount into the people that bring in and
like even now like you know eight years
into my career I still getting weekly
training with with head of L&D and the
directors and obviously you mentioned
Trev with Trev he's done some brilliant
work with us so
um yeah I think it's it's that self
analysis piece and self-awareness piece
is so so important if you don't have
that I think you can never really kind
of you can't break from being getting to
a certain level you get you'll probably
hit a peak and then if you're not
willing to take criticism or look at
your own performance and think about
what you can improve you're never going
to get to that next level so yeah no I
definitely agree with that so Sprints
then a pretty key yeah yeah we're we're
firm believer of Sprints I'm sure
there's people out there that are doing
it different ways and it and it works
for them but I think I think a lot of
people have almost gotten the complete
opposite way of like look Rob you're an
adult you know you you crack on but like
the the most common area that we find uh
recruiters score themselves lowest in
when they're looking at like what they
need to help in training is time
management productivity yeah yeah and I
actually think there's there's just a
lot to be said to like provide Rob the
recruiter with structure like I actually
think that you're actually giving Rob
the actual best chance of actually being
successful by providing him with that
structure to work around yeah and it's
and I think it's um it's really easy to
hold people accountable for stuff when
that's happening you know it's um
there's um there's guys in my team that
I know that get frustrated because they
want to book an interview as soon as
something comes through and I'm like no
no that can wait let's do it it's that
interview is not until the end of the
week let's carry on with our Sprint
because you know in in a lot of
situations unfortunately if you are um
competing against other recruiters it's
um it can be fastest finger first I hate
that it is and like we hate to have
those kind of relationships but I'd be
lying to say that we didn't like
ultimately I want to have exclusive
retained relationships so that we can do
as much due diligence on people behind
the scenes so can they so clients feel
like we've got they've got real sort of
added value service but you know when
you're first when you first won a new
business and they've you know we're not
naive to the fact they're going to have
recruitment relationships in place
already you need to work quickly yeah
back on yeah and then just final thing
then what's the rule during Sprint that
like what's the rule that is like you
can only do something that isn't the
Sprint activity unless this it's only
related to money so if it's like right
okay we've got um you know there's an
offer that's come through that we need
to we need to get closed and we know
we're up against it with other offers or
you know we've got to deal with counter
offer situations or something like that
so it's only it's only typically Revenue
related that we would break the Sprint
so you said to me five key clients in
Recruitment and you've made it
mhm yeah I you know I believe that um
five key clients that hire from you
every single month mhm to earn well in
recruitment in Tech right our average
order value is 11 Grand in the UK mhm
you do two or three placements a
month good spot yeah yeah you you're
winning aren't you really so how how
have you got your
five
um I've been doing this eight years so
like I'd be disappointed if it was less
than five at that that time yeah what
let's break down let's I do really like
that cuz again what we're doing here is
you know we're making it straightforward
and simple it's a good way to look at it
like you said cuz I think you know it
can be particularly for recruiters at
work on a 360 environment which is a lot
of recruiters
yeah like you can think I need to I need
I need all these clients or like how am
I going to get to the 300 400 500 Grand
Mark but I think you know keeping it
really simple actually if you really
work towards having five key key clients
where your average deal size is X and
you do two three a month like you're
going to be in a really strong position
yeah so like I think that's what I
really what I like about that as well
and it's a good way to think about
things yeah so cuz I'm sure you helped
your team with this so you know what
what does it look like to um yeah how do
we get to that point of having those
five key clients what's what's
fundamental what are the principles to
get in there like BD first mentality all
the time right you've always got to be
new client acquisition is so important
um you've got to be going out there and
and speak speaking to people that hire
in your space all the time um I think
there's a tendency that sometimes people
land big accounts and then they just
flip into delivery mode and it's like
you know everything's sweet I've got all
these jobs but you know I've had it
happen to me I've got complacent with it
and had a big account and they turn the
tap off and you're back to to nothing
and you need to uh you need to go back
out and win business from from scratch
again so I think spinning that plate all
the time is is new business always new
business mentality new business
mentality but like I think for actually
winning the business a really structured
like I said methodology first style to
both candidates and clients um we know
that typically clients don't buy from
you until at least nine or 10 points of
contact most recruiters stop at two or
three um and I think it's it's mixing it
up so it's not just right I'm calling
that person all the time and they're
getting frustrated I'm looking at ways
that I can actually add value to what
they're doing so you know if I know
they're hiring right now I might send
them a great candidate but I might also
talk to them about what their
competitors might be doing or to attract
top talent or what you know what um
benchmarking might they need for their
new recruitment plans and um but yeah
again I think UL it's uh it's a massive
relationship game I think over that time
I've spent a lot of time fostering those
relationships and becoming friends with
these people that I work with and they
trust me to to deliver like you got to
get that opportunity right once once
you've delivered once it's then right
okay I know I'm in I'm in a good place
here I can start building this but then
it's like I actually want to get to know
these people outside of of what they
doing work um and you can't do that
unless you're willing to put the time in
like you can't do that in a 9 to 5 day
it's actually right I'm going to spend
time with these people on the weekends
and you know it's like constantly
speaking to them and stuff that isn't
just necessarily focused around
recruitment as well um knowing what's
going on in their family lives and
things so yeah so always not getting
complacent the new business activity I
think a lot of people can relate to that
yeah and then you said around like yeah
uh like have methodologies processes M
um that you can follow yeah then
obviously said really commited to
building relationship talk to me because
you've mentioned that a few times uh
definitely as well when we like um pret
for this what on the like new business
side yeah what are some of the
methodologies processes that you really
stand by that you really drill into the
the team that you think you know really
give you and your team the best chance
of getting the outcomes that that you
want yeah I think um firstly the
database is your friend okay um so the
quality of the work that goes into the
database and the information that goes
in there is so so important I've seen
people use a database like a spreadsheet
or you know the notes are just like I
don't know you just can't even decipher
them you need the machine to like
decipher some of these notes but like um
notes to your friend right when you
spend that time speaking to to clients
understanding what their challenges are
and their needs and also who they are as
people you can come back to that because
um people going to relate to that right
they they want to know that you've
listened um listening such a big part of
of what we do so um that's so important
first making sure that your your notes
and the quality of the work that goes in
there is great I think having good
processes with your database are
important so we use bll horn so hot
lists and um regularly using them to
create and form our BD lists um we use a
lot of sort different recruitment
technology to set up campaigns as well
for outreach um and then mixing mixing
up the Outreach and we've just got a
step-by-step guide for everyone that
wants to develop so you know you you
pull some information as to someone is
hiring give that person a call straight
away first thing to understand where
they are with it if you haven't heard
back then digital touch point of some
sort LinkedIn connection requests call
MH digital touch Point invite to invite
to a a networking event um and yeah I
know like we we started to develop
ambition podcast which is like
essentially you know similar to this
where it's bringing on people that are
thought leaders or CEOs of companies to
talk about their challenges and I think
that other stuff like that it just
raises awareness for Brands and it's
interesting for for people like that
it's maybe something different than
they're not hearing from other people
because let's have it right if there's
thousands of recruiters out there that
are probably doing the same thing so you
have to differentiate yourself this
podcast is proudly partnered with vin
Cherry the all-in-one recruitment agency
software that over 20,000 recruiters
trust daily we're also partnered with
the award-winning oneup sales the sales
a motivation platform that enables you
to maximize the potential of your teams
we love partnering with both of these
these organizations because they share
our mission in helping you get the most
out of your people and your business you
can get exclusive offers because you
listen to this podcast and get up to 10%
off the usage price forever use the link
in the show notes to get your hands on
that let's get back to the episode so I
love that database is your friend and
then as you said I'm really committed to
that yeah and then also as you said yeah
you're talking about having a multi-
channel approach having a system that
you can follow yeah once somewhat yeah a
company meets certain requirements you
then you know have them uh go through
that system and yeah it's a systemized
approach that just makes Business
Development just way more easier right
you can measure it you can improve it so
how just curious then speak to a lot of
people at the moment who like I'd say
one of the common challenges I continue
to hear from recruiters is uh just
winning like better quality business
with more committed clients yeah what
what are your methodologies and
processes around that do you think that
uh which hopefully produces outcomes of
you know uh yeah clients willing to you
know give you time give you the
commitment that you need just better
quality business yeah I think that comes
down massively comes down to the
qualification and
your the open questions that you're
asking during that to try and find out
what the challenges have been and how
their other methods are working so far
and and then we we use that against a
something that we call a job
qualification Matrix so we look at that
to grade our jobs so that we're able to
prioritize our work obviously there's um
right now it's it's uh we're coming off
the back of one of the best years in
recruitment ever and
um I think the uh the commitment from
clients wasn't what it was last year
because naturally there's more
candidates available and other methods
are working and all that kind of stuff
so we've we've got a POS positively
challenge people but I think what
typically happens is when you first
engage with businesses like that where
it's like you don't feel like you've got
that commitment you know you work hard
to to get good people into the pipeline
but sometimes they almost need to they
almost need to need to lose a candidate
that they they were really excited about
for them to change um really yeah I
think so um change what though to change
their to change their processes so if
it's like right okay for example we've
got a client that
they do four or five stage interview
process or something like that you know
we would advise them at the beginning of
that process look that's too long you're
going to miss out on candidates even at
this stage we're still working with
candidates that might have three four
five other opportunities on the table if
you you know four five stage process is
going to take three to four weeks you're
going to miss out on that candidate you
know often it's like okay well if we
miss out we miss out it's not until they
have that pain factor of like I really
wanted to hire that person and then they
lose out that you can then kind of
almost start to begin to educate people
a little bit but every client's
different I think we I know one of my
one of my guys engaged with a brilliant
new client recently and their perception
of themselves were that they were quite
difficult client to please that the hire
manager had high expectations and um you
know their process was lengthy but
actually they're one of the better um
processes that we've we've worked with
in a long time and we've done six
placements in four weeks with them um
where other recruitment companies
haven't been able to to um to have that
success with them so like and I think we
spoke about a lot in his NBR actually um
this week and he was kind of surprised
that it it's gone as well as it has done
but I was like you know I feel like
that's just down to having good
structure and the fact that you only
work in this space the other the other
agencies that they're partnering with
are more generalistic that you know they
don't they don't have the network that
you have or know what they're looking
for so
um what makes what makes an a
job uh exclusivity mhm great salary
quick processes great technology great
benefits and good people like when we
speak to
candidates you ask them what the most
important thing is obviously everyone
talks about money and and technology and
all that kind of stuff but I think
ultimately the biggest thing that people
buy into is the person going work for
mhm so if you're qualifying a qualifying
a new job from someone and you feel like
I'm struggling to see how someone might
buy into this person it's going to be
difficult for you to to really sell that
role or get someone past processes when
you've got other companies the the
modern way of looking at now is that it
interviewing is a two-way street MH
candidates are interviewing clients
clients are interviewing candidates and
there's still companies out there that
aren't doing it in that way like people
should want to work for us it's just not
mentality no not the right mentality and
then what are the most common uh levers
you found that either yourself or your
team have had to pull to take jobs from
that are b c to a if the if the per if
they take the box of like the person you
can't really control that yeah yeah so
like what are the typical things that
you can you can change interview
processes um and we do a lot of work
around um the added value piece for us
is important because we we offer
technical testing solutions to all of
our clients it's worked really well
particularly with smaller brands that
maybe have had what does that mean you
you take the you you do that on behalf
of them yeah so we we um we pay for
technology Suite to be able to
technically test which sends a full
report to the client and the candidate
for them to use um and it's been great
it's um you know we we did a lot of work
over coid where we asked engineering
managers what's your biggest gripe with
working with your agency partners and
the biggest thing was having someone
that looks amazing on paper and then
they come in and they're just they just
aren't as good as as what they're
expecting like um so being able
to to um do that extra due diligence has
MA it's reduced the amount of CVS that
we send but it's massively increased our
CV to interview an interview to
placement ratio um but also like you
know we we have to take it with a bit of
a pin assault because some people people
will um present themselves better
depending on how they like to be tested
whether that's a take home test or it's
multiple choice or Theory or pair
program or whatever it is so we have to
play to the candidate strengths to give
them the best foot forward as well but I
think just adding these extra things in
has been able to uh to reduce processes
which would move something from a b to
an a grade job if you're if you're
reducing a process from five stages to
two you know that your lead time is
coming down by one or two weeks which
means that you're in a much better place
to be able to get candidates through the
process in a competitive market um
salary is always one isn't it I mean you
know if you're look if you're looking
for a mid-level engineer and they're
only willing to pay 35 and they increase
that to 45 or 50 I know that my
candidate poll drastically improves so
um yeah there's some like real basic
stuff that we can educate clients on um
as if they're willing to listen
yeah and those are the relationships
that you want to try and Foster right is
people that are open to it and I think
we set our stool out pretty well in the
in in qualifications and and new
business pictures that we're not yes
people we we we will challenge you
positively if we think what you're doing
isn't right and if it's for example a
role has been live for six months it's
probably not the it's probably not the
agencies that you're working with or the
other methods there's some problem
that's happening with you and we need to
to to dig into that to find out what
that is just curious and just for the
the technical people out there that
operate in similar markets like just
curious so the I really like that's a I
think that's that's super Innovative
that in terms of finding out that that's
a real pain and then taking on um that
challenge but so are you saying
typically then would you get candidates
to do that before you submit them to an
interview yeah yeah first stage
interview you do that before it depends
on what the what the client wants us to
run in the process you know I I think we
come to an agreement based on what we
feel is going to work for both parties
what we don't want to do is elongate the
process if they're like look use your
technical testing and then we've got to
take home test that's five hours long
I'm like we can't double test this this
candidate like um so yeah I mean ideally
yes we we'd like to we'd like to test
people first we know that's not always
going to be the way of doing it but you
know I think we're pretty we we're super
thorough in our qualification process
and when we speak to people and the fact
um like everyone in the business at
developed learns to code so we feel like
we've got a good handle on our markets
and able to properly dig into what
people's experience is rather than just
being like right okay I'm looking for
net control F on a CV and see what I can
find and see those key wordss so like um
you could give you don't have to give us
like the exact details andless you're
happy to but like what that cost how
much does it cost per test out of
interest is it expensive on average I
think people be curious that yeah I I
don't know to be fair cuz it's it's
through my yeah it's through our
operations team I know that it's a big
expense to the business and I know that
like you know Joe and Kev give us all
the tools that we need to make sure that
I think people be curious about that how
much it is to to do that you know I know
there's options out there for being able
to create free tests and things like
that and then um you know there's loads
of different testing providers codility
seems to be one that a lot of clients
are keen on using at the moment we
worked with a couple of companies that
that built test for some of our clients
as well so there's lots of different but
yeah it's going to cost you money but is
a great added value pitch to take to new
people because when you're speaking to
to new businesses and they ask what
you're doing that's different it's
something that s that does differentiate
us so just just curious then like your
Market must be so competitive
yeah so you've mentioned a few things
podcast you know salary surveys this
talking
about like how how have you and how do
you help your team like genuinely like
stand out and like you know be perceived
as not just another tech recruiter
because I feel like Cur if I'm wrong but
obviously net as well specifically
that's going to be even more competitive
yeah it's super competitive and you've
done that for eight years I love
it but like how have you how have you
like continued ly remained do you know
what I mean relevant um you know stood
out different cuz that's hard yeah yeah
yeah it definitely is and I think like I
said the the coding um piece that we're
doing I think is a is a genuine USP I
don't know many other uh recruitment
companies that that pay for Udi and
plural site licenses for their
Consultants to learn to code um we
always say to people that you you know
you not going to want to hire me right
now based my code super messy but like
it just enables us to engage with our
Market on on a deeper level and I think
like when I started I started punching
out code on LinkedIn and screenshots and
stuff like that and I had CTO that I've
been trying to engage with for a year
coming to me or like lead developers are
coming to me and saying you know you
could do this you could change that have
you thought about these different
principles do you want to do a pairing
session so like all that kind of stuff
just kind of shows that you can go in
and say you're you're a specialist in
the space um and I think that's really
difficult isn't it cuz everyone that
kind of gets into recruitment they're
told immediately to put right day one
you're a specialist.net recruitment and
uh fake it to you make it basically um
but you can't you you generally can't be
a specialist until you've spent time
understanding exactly what what you
recruiting what what that's designed to
do um how long do you think that takes
um typically what's the stat is it a, th
hours before before you come an expert
um if you break that down like based on
the amount on the working week and
you're you're an expert within a year
according to that stat but I think you
can you can learn really good
recruitment principles within that time
but learning technology it's some of
these people are doing it for 5 10 15
years before they're sort really
experienc people so you can't
underestimate it um but I think I I used
to spent like in my first year I just
picked a topic every week that I wanted
to learn about and I'd speak to one
candidate or client about it and then I
would take that information into my next
call so for example like at the time
when I first saw NBC um was a framework
that was um yeah was was really hot so I
was like well I'm going to I'm going to
ask people about the like what's what's
good about it what the challenges are
and um and then I just take it into new
conversations and it just you know open
like technology like Engineers want to
speak about technology and new things
that are happening so I think if you're
consistently getting involved in those
kind of markets and and have a passion
for it I think um people that had taken
one thing each week I think that's good
that's that's really practical advice
people yeah I mean it definitely helps
you you you build your knowledge base
really quickly um and I think it's
really easy in your early stages of your
recruitment career to lose credibility
if you say the name of a technology or
framework wrong yeah people people w't
buying to you so being able to have that
that sort of in-depth technical
conversation with people differentiates
us um I think it's a lot down to the
person as well like I take a lot I feel
like our business we probably take a bit
of a gentler approach to selling and um
I like to think of it as an experience I
want everyone to have a brilliant
experience with me um so sometimes it
takes bit of time for people to uh to um
give us that opportunity but if you're
persistent with
it get the opportunity and then you've
just got to work and graft to make sure
that that person has a brilliant
experience how have you how have you
made sure that you don't get complacent
cuz I've spoken to a lot of people that
you know they have on their goal sheet
and big capital letters on and become
the top performer yeah they get there
and they really struggle to then
you know then like continue on that path
it's way more easier like chasing that
than like retaining it I've just found
when speaking to people and you you've
continued to go in that positive
direction um but like yeah how have you
just how have you maintained that
personally I think it's really difficult
to get complacent in recruitment if you
do you fall on your face pretty quickly
um even now like I've I've had
situations where I've been blindsided in
certain things and I think you know i'
I'm eight years in now I should know
this but I've still dropped a ball
somewhere and then it's like right okay
I need to I need to learn from that and
sharpen my tool set in that area so I
think it's I'm I'm super fortunate to
work for a business that invests so much
in its people that's um that's the key
to not getting complacent is that
commitment to learning all the time um I
think even you know you could be the you
could be doing recruitment for 20 30
years and be the best biller ever you
still got something that you could work
on and improve and that's the that's the
beauty of the industry like you're
always although it can feel sometimes
it's a bit mundane and what we do is
quite simple really there's always going
to be different nuances or different
situations that kind of humble you a
little bit which is um which makes it
really difficult I think to to be
complacent but you've got to have that
drive to want to be at the top I'm like
I'm not a um super materialistic person
but I'm pretty competitive like I I you
know I'm I'm not top performer this year
and this is that's the first time it's
goingon to be like that obviously I'm
running the team yeah yeah yeah so uh
Tom Gall I'm coming for
you like just in interesed because I you
know I I meet these people or because I
speak to companies about training these
things yeah how how do you approach
communicating dealing with people who
are maybe three four years in they might
have been a top performer or might put
some you know really good performances
and and you've just got that they've got
that sense of like I've completed
recruitment or Rob I know what I'm
doing mate cuz I'm sure you've
had to navigate with people like that
and like this is like for everyone
listen this is like one of the most
common things I always find in people
that have been in recruitment for a long
time have been in consistent top perform
is like the way you're describing your
learning that you're always open to it
it's continuous learning and that's
that's absolutely the mindset you have
to have yeah but there's people out
there that think that they know best and
think that they like why would I learn
from Rob like why am I going to learn
from this person they haven't been doing
it as long as me like how have you
navigate approach that with people it's
really difficult it's person to person
isn't it and it it kind of depends
on there's a massive ego piece isn't
there and confidence piece that you find
typically with top billers and people
that are performing at a high level I
think it's I've always just dealt with
it
by offering like I've been in a
fortunate position that no one's out bu
me for eight years in the business so
like if anyone they should listen
to yeah yeah but I'm not I'm not um
completely closed off to the fact that
I'm not perfect either and that there
people will be doing different things
that are having lots of different
success so I think um being open to
taking criticism from people that are
below me kind of create breaks down
those barriers to be able to have those
kind of conversations but um I spend a
lot of time even with my top billers
just offering coaching advice and
spending time listen
calls and looking at stuff so to see
that they can prove and I think people
will buy into you if they know that
you're looking to help them improve and
help them earn more money like if
they're not open to
that all for them really isn't it but
it's
just yeah it's that's a difficult one to
deal with I think I've definitely
managed people that kind of feel like
they you know they've they've been very
good recruiters but still stuff to learn
um I think you've kind of almost got to
force that Force those coaching sessions
on them and and bring things to their
attention that they they maybe didn't
realize that they were
doing so as you get to the the end of
this year then yeah like we saying
earlier you know it's been difficult for
a lot of people yeah what are you being
you know you're big into your Sprints
Focus productivity what are you and the
team you know for the remainder this
year remaining laser laser focused on um
new client acquisition is still a
massive thing for us um I I want us to
be able to um to build out the team so
that we can cover every specialism the
way that we're set up at the moment is
that we have specialist for both net
Java JavaScript PHP python um and then I
have a a small delivery function that
kind of picks up all Niche more Niche
skill sets but I'd like to open up new
markets um
But ultimately we just need to get the
get the team back on track it's I feel
like it's been a difficult year for a
lot of people in recruitment after that
sort of crazy year we had last year um
and it's again the focus on customer
first customer having a brilliant
experience with with us both clients and
candidates we implemented um net
promoter score recently so uh our our
big Focus as a business is to uh to make
sure that our net promoter score is
everyone is uh is a promoter of our
business and everyone has a brilliant
experience and I think that's just
sharpening our um our processes even
more um so yeah customer experience love
it Rob it's been a pleasure absolutely